comenzó la diosa Benedicto 16 el cuerpo
del Papa emérito fue trasladado hasta la
Basílica de San Pedro en las primeras
horas del lunes donde permanecerá hasta
el miércoles para que miles de fieles
puedan presentarles sus respetos y
despedirse
[Música]
En comparación con un funeral Esta es
una ocasión en la que tienes una
experiencia más personal vinimos a decir
gracias a preguntar algo Tienes la
sensación de estar frente a alguien que
llegó al otro lado ha sido una oración
hermosa
a nivel diplomático las únicas
autoridades invitadas Serán las de
Italia y Alemania informó El Vaticano
resaltó la presencia de la primera
ministra Georgia Melanie y el presidente
Sergio matarella Mientras que el jefe de
la conferencia episcopal alemana abrió
un libro de condolencias para Benedicto
estoy impresionado y personalmente muy
conmovido por la gran participación
sobre la muerte del Papa emérito
Benedicto XVI muchas personas han tomado
parte en esto
las iglesias participando en oraciones
encendiendo velas y escribiendo en los
libros de condolencias
la muerte de Benedicto a sus 95 años
dejó al Vaticano en una situación
inédita en más de seis siglos no existen
estatutos para el fallecimiento de un
Papa emérito Lo cierto es que su
entierro se llevará a cabo el 5 de enero
en la plaza de San Pedro y la misa La
celebrará el Papa Francisco siguiendo
sus propios deseos el cuerpo de
Benedicto 16 descansarán las criptas
bajo la basílica en el mismo lugar donde
fue enterrado el papa Juan Pablo II en
el año 2005